[Music]
on this wednesday night quebec's covert
vaccine passport takes effect
fewer freedoms for those who didn't get
the shot i know it's a choice that we
make not to be vaccinated but we used to
be allowed to make that choice plus how
ontario's new system will work the
liberals platform and the price tag this
is the plan that canada needs the
promises aimed at parents the
self-employed and afghan refugees a
liberal candidate accused of
inappropriate behavior the criticism
against the party for standing by raj
saney and smashing records the canadian
paralympians on top of the world
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us as canada heads into the fall with
rising covid19 cases the debate is
heating up over the degree to which the
country should use vaccine passports
today quebec became the first province
to put one into practice the passports
are essentially certificates which
confirm vaccinations and allow people to
do things like eat out at restaurants
work out at gyms or attend live concerts
ontario manitoba saskatchewan and bc are
introducing their own plans for
passports this country is in a fourth
wave and it's the western provinces that
are largely driving it bc alberta and
saskatchewan have much higher rates of
active cases per 100 000 people compared
to provinces in the east including
ontario whose population is larger than
all three of those provinces combined
the northwest territories may have the
smallest population but it has the
highest rate of active cases per 100 000
people
this is day one of vaccine passports in
quebec and there's a so-called two-week
probation period before possible fines
in our top story tonight mike armstrong
has a look at the rollout and the
resistance
there is a new sound quebecers are
having to get used to that little beep
without it there are going to be some
serious limitations on what people can
and can't do
basically before leaving home you
download the province's vacci code app
and enter your proof of vaccination if
you want to do something like enjoy a
cold one on a terrace that's a patio for
the rest of the country i did it
yesterday and it went really well i
thought it was going to be longer and
took a couple seconds and i was good to
go very minimal i think it took two
minutes of my day i opened my vacci code
now quebec is the first province
territory or state in north america with
a vaccine passport
there's been an ad campaign for a couple
of weeks warning people to get ready
beginning in september you'll need a
vaccination passport to enter certain
public spaces don't wait until it hits
you get vaccinated
the government has been predicting some
hiccups with the rollout the health
minister said it could be at first in
his words rock and roll the manager of
this restaurant says he's been nervous
for days as it turns out for nothing so
far so good i have to admit uh one
person didn't have it so we decided to
take a take out instead it was really
understandable
the vaccine app or a printed proof of
vaccination is now required for places
like gyms movie theaters bars and
restaurants after a two-week grace
period fines could run up to six
thousand dollars
not everyone is happy when the pilot
project was announced opponents turned
up outside the quebec city restaurant
where the app was being tested there was
also a protest in montreal we're
supposed to have medical freedom in
canada and it's difficult seeing i know
it's a choice that we make not to be
vaccinated but we used to be allowed to
make that choice
now the vaccine code is not required for
services like salons or driving schools
things the government deems essential
but there are appeals for that to change
this hairdresser says she will employ
the app you know this tool is now
available
and i intend to use it she says she'll
ask customers who don't have it to go
somewhere else
mike armstrong global news montreal
ontario residents will soon have to show
proof they've been fully vaccinated the
province rolled out the details for its
vaccine passport it's the fifth province
to mandate proof of vaccination but as
jamie maracher explains the patchwork of
passports across the country comes with
concerns
after months of refusing a provincial
vaccine certification system ontario's
premier says the fourth wave forced his
hand there's no secret that
you know i wasn't in favor of this
starting september 22nd indoor settings
like restaurants bars nightclubs event
spaces and casinos will require anyone
over 12 to show their full covet 19
vaccination status before entry the
venues that we have chosen are
responsive to the risk that we've found
in ontario the vaccination won't be
mandatory for workers at those
businesses our membership which is about
38 000 small and medium-sized businesses
across ontario are extremely split on
this issue
it's very contentious retail spaces
salons banks essential services and
patios will not require proof of
vaccination in ontario those who are
double dosed will be able to request a
personal qr code on october 22nd this
can be stored on your phone or printed
menus will scan the code along with
checking a piece of id like a driver's
license or health card to gain entry
ontario becomes the fifth province to
release plans for vaccine passports
creating a growing patchwork of policies
nationally had we had
an opportunity to have a national
certificate we may have been able to
establish some national protocols for
response to the app going down to the qr
code not scanning correctly imagine
traveling around even canada with 13
different vaccination certificates
it would have been much easier if we had
one passport federal passport so while
it's not what premier ford had hoped for
like the fourth wave the passport's here
now and ontarians will have to live with
it jamie morocco global news toronto
the federal campaign has officially hit
the halfway point there are now just 18
days until the election polls show the
race is tightening and today the
liberals unveiled their full platform
including how much their promises will
cost the 82 page document called forward
for everyone is the first fully costed
platform to be released it proposes 78
billion dollars in new spending over the
next five years there's no timeline for
balancing the budget though justin
trudeau pitched the plan as ambitious
and responsible
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is traveling with the liberals he
joins us now with details on the
promises and the price tag david robin
all the parties in this election are
willing to spend billions to get your
vote and the liberal party is no
different it's a platform of promises
that if implemented would add billions
to the national debt this is a
responsible budget
it's a tren sorry this is a responsible
platform it is a transparent platform uh
it is one where we really welcome
scrutiny well the liberals have already
outlined many other campaign promises
there are some new spending commitments
today including the self-employed will
be able to participate in the employment
insurance system with the government
picking up the tab for some premiums
new parents can pause repayment of
student loans until their youngest child
is five and there's 350 million dollars
to help settle twenty thousand
afghanistan refugees the spending
promises new and previously announced
tally up to 78 billion dollars over five
years now new revenue measures though
only add up to 25 billion dollars over
five years the big new one today a
minimum tax for high income earners the
liberals say those with a taxable income
of more than two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars will pay a minimum tax
of fifteen percent the liberal platform
which actually goes into much more
detail than the ndp platform is a very
specific measure there are also some new
promises that do not have a price tag
for example the liberals will prohibit
the rcmp from using so-called choke
holds or using tear gas and rubber
bullets for crowd control the liberals
also promised to change the canada
health act to force provinces to provide
publicly financed equitable access to
abortion
we need to be a country that stands
unequivocally for women's rights
for a woman's right to choose effective
referral is really important to have in
place especially in rural and remote
communities where in fact there is no
ability to refer now all told what's in
this election platform from the liberals
would add 19 billion dollars to this
year's federal deficit but the liberals
argue that the debt to gdp ratio would
actually decline because they say partly
as a result of some of the spending
measures here the economy will grow
quicker then government spending will
grow robin
david how might this platform help the
liberals with their key objective
obviously winning the election
well the liberals here were boasting
that this election platform is the most
progressive platform ever put forward by
a federal liberal party i would tend to
agree with that and for that reason it
is aimed straight at those ndp and block
quebecois voters that the liberals
absolutely have to have come back to
their side of the ledger in order to win
the government robin david aiken in
toronto thanks david
the liberal leader is taking heat for
standing by a candidate facing
allegations of misconduct raj sani is
seeking re-election in the ontario
riding of kitchener center which he
represented for the past six years women
who worked for the liberals including
one woman in saney's office have accused
him of inappropriate behavior in the
past trudeau has said he has zero
tolerance for sexual misconduct towards
women as our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson explains concerns
about saney's behavior were brought all
the way up to the prime minister's
office
it gives me great pride to rise today
concerns about liberal mp raj saney
first landed in the prime minister's
office soon after the trudeau government
was first elected because it's 2015.
promoting a feminist agenda
justin trudeau had just one year earlier
acted quickly to remove two mps scott
andrews and massimo pachetti from the
liberal caucus following allegations of
sexual harassment allegations both men
denied but after the election a source
with direct knowledge of the situation
says senior staff in the new pmo did not
act when they were warned of allegations
of inappropriate behavior by two other
mps at the 2015 liberal christmas party
marwan tabarra would be charged with two
counts of assault as well as one count
of criminal harassment break and enter
and committing an indictable offense in
2020 and raj saney the current mp for
kitchener center who is running for
reelection despite multiple allegations
of inappropriate and unwanted sexual
behavior during his time in office
global news spoke with two women who
raised concerns about saney with senior
liberals and say the prime minister's
chief of staff katie telford was aware
one woman who worked for saney as a
senior staffer complained of unwelcome
sexual advances harassing behavior and
psychological abuse she says saying he
yelled and threw things at work and that
the subsequent stress contributed to
intense emotional duress telling global
news she once tried to take her own life
while in saney's office saney told
global news he never acted
inappropriately toward staff saying i
take the health and safety of all of my
staff extremely seriously liberal leader
justin trudeau has cleared saney to run
we make sure that there are proper
rigorous processes that everyone gets to
go through
when they come forward with concerns and
allegations
trudeau and saney have said a workplace
assessment was conducted and found no
concerns about harassment but the woman
who complained says she was never
interviewed as part of the review
two women who worked in senior positions
for the liberal party say they feel the
pmo and the party are saying one thing
and doing another robin mercedes
stephenson in ottawa thanks mercedes
conservative leader erin o'toole is
campaigning on the party's plan to build
key infrastructure including public
transit roads and 5g telecom networks if
elected he's also promising to scrap the
liberal government's infrastructure bank
aimed at attracting private dollars for
public projects but that all comes with
a price and o'toole is being grilled
about how he'll balance the budget
michael couture is traveling with the
conservatives mike robin as aaron
o'toole was taking swipes at the liberal
platform the conservative leader was
also taking heat for his promise to
balance the budget within 10 years of
taking power
according to the parliamentary budget
officer this fiscal year's deficit is
just over 138 billion dollars o'toole's
platform hasn't been fully costed just
yet but he insists he can still get back
to zero deficits without austerity we're
going to
create jobs and opportunity
build infrastructure that mr trudeau
announces but never gets built and have
a detailed plan and a disciplined plan
to get spending under control to balance
the budget over the course of 10 years a
part of the conservative plan is based
on canada having gdp growth of 3 percent
annually an assumption that some say is
a little too ambitious we may get it for
one one year or two years that that is
possible but that's that's suggested for
one or two years because we are coming
out of the pandemic and that's it sort
of a special case but then we are going
to go back to our sort of normal
growth economist mostafa ascari says
historically canada hasn't sustained a
three percent growth rate over time
adding it's hard to see the conservative
path to balance without a fully costed
platform on that point aaron o'toole
says the party asks the parliamentary
budget officer to look at their numbers
and will update his platform when the
pbo reports back to them
robin mike likature in montreal where
quebec is shaping up to be a
battleground coming up the ndp's mission
to make a comeback in la belle provence
the battle for votes in quebec is headed
towards a showdown between the liberals
and the black quebecois but the new
democrats are confident they have a shot
too that's despite the ndp all but
disappearing from quebec in the 2019
election abigail beeman is traveling
with the party and looks at what a
comeback could look like abigail
robin the ndp feel optimistic as they
target quebec perhaps a little too
optimistic depending who you ask but
they have nowhere to go but up in 2019
they went from having 16 seats all the
way down to one things feel really
different where we have a track record
to run on where we've shown canadians
what you get with new democrats and
that's made a big difference
people come up to us all the time saying
thank you for saving my job thank you
for fighting to increase the weight
subsidy party sources say they're
targeting between four and ten ridings
more liberal than bloc including cabinet
ministers such as stephen gilbeau they
have several ousted mps returning again
including what they hope is some star
power in a former member of the 2011
orange crush ruth allen brasso in 2019
jagmeet singh's opposition to bill 21
quebec's ban on religious symbols turned
out to be an insurmountable problem and
he faced racism directly on the campaign
trail from voters who did not want a
prime minister who wears a turban you
should cut your
turban off and you put you look like a
canadian but the ndp's last man standing
in quebec says he's not hearing those
concerns at the door now i'm quite
confident i will not be the only quebec
mp next time
leader jagmeet singh stays in montreal
to prepare for a french language debate
thursday night his wife cast her ballot
here wednesday with voter turnout even
more critical this pandemic election the
party hopes that will send a message
that it's easy to vote even when you're
not in your home riding robin abigail
beeman in montreal thanks abigail
the assembly of first nations lays out
its top wishes for federal leaders
that's straight ahead
the assembly of first nations is
weighing in on the federal election with
its top priorities for the federal
leaders the attention put on residential
schools and wildfires affecting first
nations communities made headlines in
2021 now the hope is that they don't
fade from the election spotlight
for decades indigenous people tried to
tell canada the truth about the harm
done by residential schools their
children taken away their culture erased
then in 2021 the discovery of suspected
graves at the kamloops indian
residential school finally got the
attention of the country if you're a
first nations person in in canada right
now
you've been affected by the residential
school legacy the assembly of first
nations representing 900 000 indigenous
people is demanding federal leaders
provide resources to investigate what
happened to the children at these
schools it also wants the next federal
government to fund a national indigenous
healing organization to deal with the
mental health implications we have to
talk about it and that's the bottom line
they over the next few years we'll find
more and more of these unmarked grades
this is an ongoing concern for first
nations truth and reconciliation will
always be a top priority but there's
also climate change
the wildfires right across canada have
displaced many canadians but in remote
parts it's often first nations people
that have to worry about losing their
homes the most they blame climate change
the world is getting sick and what we're
seeing is the reaction of this sickness
there are demands for the basic human
right of clean drinking water better
schools and control of its own health
care system to avoid the racist
treatment that joyce eshequan
experienced before dying at a quebec
hospital
so this election is more than any in the
past uh involves a canadian electoral
population that is more engaged and
supportive of first nation issues vafn
won't endorse any party the hope from
all indigenous leaders is that they'll
all listen if they put more political
will
into those commitments you're going to
see a better country
our coverage of the 2021 federal
election campaign includes a trip across
the country and global national is back
on the road tomorrow donna friesen joins
us now with where she's headed next hi
donna
hi robin we have headed north from
calgary to alberta's capital if justin
trudeau is going to get the majority he
is seeking he'll be hoping to pick up
the couple of liberal seats he lost here
in 2019. right now though that is
looking like a stretch the liberal
government not surprisingly is not
popular here in alberta what's
interesting though is that the
conservative premier jason kenney is
also deeply unpopular in part because of
the way he's handled the pandemic
alberta is in the midst of a fourth wave
right now covid cases are soaring again
hospital icus are filling up again and
the premier well he's been on vacation
for weeks there have been no public
health briefings at all lately
and yet his party is selling this as a
fundraiser a hat that says best summer
ever
so lots to talk about from edmonton
tomorrow robin all right good stuff
donna
and from edmonton global national we'll
head to bedeck nova scotia in cape
breton and eventually wind up in ottawa
just ahead of election night
up next a banner day at the paralympic
games canada adds more medals to its
count
it was canada's most successful day yet
at the paralympic games with two
record-breaking gold medals and a silver
swimmer early river struck gold for a
second time in tokyo the 25 year old
from quebec also broke her own world
record in the women's s10 400 meter
freestyle the gold medal is revival's
fourth time on the podium in tokyo
vancouver's greg stewart also set a new
paralympic record in the men's f-46 shot
put he threw a whopping distance of
16.75 meters on his first attempt no one
was able to match it through the six
rounds
and wheelchair racer brent lacitos has
added another medal to his haul at the
games he nabbed silver in the men's t-53
100 meter final it's the quebec native's
third silver medal of the games and his
tenth time on the paralympic podium
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is narrowmadabc we'd love to
see your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and be sure to
tune in tomorrow when donna freezen will
broadcast from edmonton until then have
a great night
[Music]